as that one bounced right back to COV and up
ahead now is Dick perck perck centering pass
redirected by the Rangers and a lead pass up the
ice stepping in it's a two on0 across they score
artmi panarin an odd man rush and the Rangers did
not miss less than two minutes in it's one nothing
the show for the New York Rangers tough lock there
for Victor hman he just blows a tire at exactly
the wrong time the crossy pass and the timing is
perfect tro is having an outstanding season and
when you're having a big season some luck follows
you that was pure luck takes advantage of headman
makes the pass at exactly the right time panan
is ready here's mod the backjack L forier try
to tuck it in pad down with vasilki Rangers with
some pressure here into the corner swep around
by tro troble with a drive save rebound they
score Vincent troch tucks it home and it is two
nothing get the puck inside the Zone use your
pointment and then go to the net really hard
look at the lightning blue shirts lots of guys
back how are you going to play When the puck
comes from the point are you going to pick guys
up ahead of time it's a 2on one in front of the
net Victor Hedman got stranded out on that left
side there and never got back to the front of
the net in time he lost his man there and it was
troch he was with troch for a second perix is in
front of the net he's got a man tied up but
he can only take one and it's the extra Guy
the two-on one that wins it there b centers it
that one's into this gate but picked up by aimont
aimont cut back move then another one he throws
it back up top here's danan his Drive stopped by
just Sten rebound picked up by Ayan raer and he
scores Mikey gets the liing on the board and it's
2-1 referee had his hand up in the air was going
to call a penalty I'm not sure on who I think it
was on the Rangers but what they're saying is
I think that there was interference on their
goenda and from that line asmon's really good
Around the Net he's got quick feet we've seen
him do these wraparound before that one was
in cleanly they'll be looking at this though
there's the Collision in the crease area but
that's not what pushed shurin out of the net
in my view at least he ended up four or five ft
outside the paint and had to recover so far to
The Far Side there's another look at it see
look at sherka sh Jen goes there of his own
accord that shouldn't be a problem for me that
should be fine this should this goal should
stand Brandon blandina and Peter McDougall Are
the referees here tonight they are on the headset
with the Situation Room in Toronto looking
at this one and I got to agree with you that
sherka did push away from the goal yeah at the
conclusion of that play that that part made no
sense to me now of course gold was scored so he's
going to complain and yes he bumped into that's
very easy to see but did it have a bearing
on the goal to me more of a bearing was the
fact that he pushed out here we go after coach's
challenge video review it was determined there was
goenda into the line lead for aimon his drive
and a glove save made by shurin aimon with a
quick shot he's had a couple of great chances
tonight and now it's a breakaway pass barklay
goodro in stopped by basoski he clears the
rebound back up the ice hay flurry calling
forward is Hegel on the right side stops HS on in
for Celli back to chck and shoots save by shurkin
here's Hond gathers the puck he'll bang it back
to points and point picks up some speed down
the right side stops up leaves it for COV krov
sweeps his way in and they set up flip pass back
to Heaven here St goes save rebound another one
for Point Pucket still lose St goes across shoots
star there it is Nik CRA gets the lightning
on the board 21 they were just not going to
be stopped here I think lingren made a save
here I thought oh my goodness how did this
not go in braid point right there I think
lingren made that Save Right outside the
crease area but the lightning don't stop and
that's the key stamp go is quick to jump on
it there's the play lingren is down and out the
goal tender is down and out he's pushed off to
one side and right out of it lingren tries
to play goenda finds a way to go five hole
being tipped of the way through so it goes
all the way into the Rangers corner9 mod up
there along with Brandon Hegel now Celli gets
after the corner Rangers dump it down here's
potential two-on-one tro puts it across shot
scores Chris krider answers right back for New
York this was a set play by the Rangers and the
lightning Defenders didn't recognize a quick
clean up corner and this is a flip play gan's not
looking at what's coming at him radish is but it's
another outnumbered attack and the execution is
perfect tro who has been just on fire the entire
season and was having a heck of a game again that
is as good a pass as you can make little bit of an
aerial but it lands right on krider's stick with
Pace KRA in the middle drops it off hangle inside
for Point never got the rebound headman and shurin
came way out shot from Jano was blocked tro Park
is really bouncing around all over the place and
now here comes paner V era trying to get loose
scores our timy panan with an absolute dagger
here in the third period in the ranger Zone
they look like they were going to keep it in
the zone and then there's chernak who ends
up getting crossed over on the left side which
leaves headman backing everybody up well that's
what he had to do with back up and when you
have that big a gap Panera knows exactly how
to use it see how he protects the puck Victor
did pretty much everything he could do and
then Panera just makes a beautiful shot hangs on
hangs on vasileski is they come in Over The Line
Savannah Jad was headed for the net that was cut
off by flurry lead pass up ahead for Paul Paul's
in oh he got it behind sh and it's pulled off the
line there by wheeler getting the puck up quickly
from Zone Zone catches the Rangers Paul gets a
good bounce now Paul's going to fight it right
into the crease area oh my goodness how did that
not go in and yeah it is fox fox comes and clears
it away with his glove nice little move how about
that save oh my goodness with the stick backwards
and then that's where he gets the help from
Fox who Scoops it out from off the line look
at that stick work talk about never giving up
on a play you can tell that he's working with
jonath the quick as his Timmy paner with the
puck got a couple Tonight download to fox fox
in the corner back to paner paner to Fox Panera
shoots scores and it is a hatch trick for our timi
paner it it didn't really have to worry too
much about Fox there just stay out on paner
paner the one who had the best angle so
chernak probably should have stayed a
little more in the middle of the ice wait
to see if Fox is going to walk out of the
corner but that shot just handcuffs vasileski
I don't think it was deflect star of the show
are Timmy panan with a hattick tonight and this
one is over 51 final for the New York Rangers